ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello and
welcome to another episode of
Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagarajan.
KALYAN REDDY: And I'm
Kalyan Reddy.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: This
is Google Apps
Unscripted July, 2013 edition.
So this is our monthly office
hours slash announcements, and
just general discussion
GDL that we do.
We've started doing this, I
think for a few months now,
and it has been really,
really successful.
And I'm really excited
to see all the people
jump in, ask questions.
And we're deep in the summer,
so really excited to pick up
the pace and have a lot of
announcements and really cool
things that we're working on.
We'll be sharing that
with you very soon.
KALYAN REDDY: If you're tuning
in live, we're going to start
with release notes and
other new and cool
features and app script.
We'll get to your questions
towards the second half.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah, to give us about 10
minutes to bring up to speed
on what we've done
so far in July.
And then we'll save plenty of
time for Q&A. So Kalyan, do
you want to start us off with
release notes and the two
releases we've done
so far this month?
KALYAN REDDY: Sure.
Oh, and by the way, there's a
Hangouts link as well so you
can join us there and you can
chime in with your questions
and we'll try our best
to answer them.
All right.
Let's go ahead and get started
with release notes here.
We've had two releases so far
in July since our last Apps
Unscripted.
The first one here on July 9,
we added a new XML Service.
This is actually a direct
replacement for our old XML
Service and it features several
improvements here.
Our colleague [? Eric Coleta ?],
you might
know him from previous
episodes--
he created this blog post that
you should check out on our
Apps Script blog,
googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com.
He basically goes through a very
simple example of how you
create various elements with
the new XML Service.
[INAUDIBLE]
inbox threads, put them as
XML elements, give them
attributes and such.
And it's all very
straightforward.
So it's worth checking out.
One thing you'll notice is that
if you're familiar with
jdom this should look similar,
and you should have no trouble
getting started with that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: An important
thing to note here is that the
old one that we deprecated is
just called XML, which is a
little confusing and
inconsistent with some of the
other services that we have.
So the new one is called XML
Service, and it's easier to
find and easier to use.
KALYAN REDDY: And so if you're
looking for the documentation,
it's in the same place as the
old one except you'll see the
old as it's actually deprecated
down here.
That's the old service.
And then the new one is here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So just keep
that in mind when you're
searching for this.
KALYAN REDDY: So along with that
we also deprecated the
[INAUDIBLE] service so now
you're able to just use the
new XML Service with your URL
fetch app and replicate a lot
of the functionality.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
You can template an XML file as
well so you could use the
HTML services templating
capability depopulate your XML
template, if you have one, or
as most API's have gone JSON
and REST-based services have
kind of taken over.
So obviously we provide a really
good support for that
for a long time.
So keep that in mind as well.
KALYAN REDDY: All right,
let's see.
Some issue fixes here.
One is that, if you were using
the advanced Google services--
again, these are things
like URL Shortener--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Tasks.
KALYAN REDDY: --that live
under-- yeah, tasks that live
under the advanced google
services tab in our
documentation, if you're using
those, there was a slight
problem in which if you were
chaining method calls together
instead of doing each method
on a separate line as a
different statement then
there was an error.
And that's no longer [INAUDIBLE]
temporary issue
that we fixed.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
We apologize for those issues.
If you did change your code to
not chain them, it's OK.
You can leave it as such.
But if you're copying and
pasting our samples or you
want to keep your code
really succinct, you
can change them again.
KALYAN REDDY: And finally
the remove editor
method on a file object.
It no longer throws an exception
when the editor is a
group and not an individual
user.
Let's see.
On the July 22 release we added
two of our new services
that we released
in the I/O time
frame that you'll remember.
We added that to the app
script dashboard.
So now you can get alerts
whenever a service has
reliability issues or
something for a day.
You'll see that tracked.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
And dashboard is actually--
I think it's
script.google.com/dashboard.
Is that right?
KALYAN REDDY: Yep.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Script.google.com/dashboard.
If you think you're
having an issue--
I think I have the URL right.
Let's just quickly verify
and see if I--
KALYAN REDDY: Let's
quiz our own here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes!
KALYAN REDDY: There we go.
Alright.
So you'll see there here
[INAUDIBLE] up in format for
the two that we added.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So if you think you're having
some issue or outage, make
sure you check there.
That'll be a really good
indication of what's going on.
And it took us a while to put
it up there, but now you can
check there for the new services
we launched as well.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
And this interesting issue
that we fixed, it came up
basically when you exposed a
script as a web app, there
were certain URL parameters that
were getting, like, cut.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think one was question
mark PLI equals 1.
And you would think, you know,
why now just use other
parameters?
But there's certain
organizations where they by
default require these.
There's some special
meaning to them.
In any case, we fixed it such
that now you can use whatever
parameter you want.
All of them will get past to
your application without being
trimmed of cut.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
I think it mostly came up when
you had a web app embedded
into a google site and there
were certain parameters either
added in manually or
automatically by some system,
and the web app never got
those parameters.
So we fixed that.
KALYAN REDDY: Awesome.
That's it for release notes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
The two releases and hopefully
I'll kind of walk you through
what we've added or updated, or
in one case deprecated and
replaced with something
better.
KALYAN REDDY: There's also
another nice addition here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
So one of the things that we
didn't really make it part of
the release notes,
but we think it's
really big and important.
It's sort of the top post right
now on our developer
blog is the end user experience
of authorizing your
application.
It just got probably, I don't
know, ten times, a hundred
times better.
It's been one of the long term
pain points that we've heard
from a lot of different
developers.
The developers that started
working on the platform
several years ago I think have
gotten used to this by now,
but hopefully the new developers
and the new users
you're acquiring are
experiencing a much nicer
authorization process.
Essentially what this is going
to be now is a very standard
authorization process that an
end user sees, that they see
when they authorize a standard
web app that's built on Google
technologies.
That's using OAuth2,
generally speaking.
And they get a really nice
screen that's very clean and
concise, tells the user what
your script is trying to do,
and then they get a very
straightforward blue accept
button where they can authorize
your application.
None of this sort of red screen
if it's asking for some
extra permissions, your email
address is not front and
center in the authorization
dialogue--
KALYAN REDDY: Different
color border.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Different
color borders.
KALYAN REDDY: I know a lot of
long-time app scripters are
like, back in my day--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
You probably are upset this
it's taken this long.
But it took us a lot of effort
to make sure this is
consistent, this is without
any issues.
If you remember, actually back
in I/O, we launched it as an
opt-in only option for
a script developer.
So they could upgrade the
authorization experience
through a menu option.
We've now made this
the default.
So if you create a new script
it will now take this
capability on.
The existing scripts, you
still need to upgrade it
yourself because it is, we
think, an important decision
our developer makes rather than
us just flipping them off
or flipping them on
for everything.
But you should definitely
check this out.
I think it's going to be, in
the long run, a really good
developer and user experience.
So just to kind of show you what
this means, if you take a
look at the blog posts these
are two screenshots of the
same authorization experience
for an end user.
So I forget what
the script is.
I think this is Gmail Snooze.
Gmail Snooze, very popular
script, allows you to attach a
label to a Gmail thread and
say, resurface this in x
number of minutes or
hours or days.
Notice the difference
in the look and
feel for the end user.
The first one has the email
address actually blacked out
because we didn't want that
to be in the post.
But you can see that it's
a lot less scary.
End users now will be more
likely to authorize your
script, or at least they're
not going to
be startled by it.
There's some really nice
benefits because of this.
So first of all, the
cleanliness and the
consistency is really
important.
But if you actually go and
create a new script--
let's just talk from
our developer's
standpoint for a second--
script.google.com, logged in
here as client's test account.
So this is going to
create a script.
I'm just going to call
it GDL test.
The first thing that I'll do
is just do a really simple
Gmail app dot get aliases.
A really simple thing that,
by itself, it's
not going to do anything.
But if I hit run the script
obviously checks the code and
makes sure that authorization
is required.
Click on the authorize
dialogue.
A pop up comes up, really
nice consistent pop up.
And then it kind of has the
ability Kalyan to actually
switch authorization.
Once he's actually logged into
multiple accounts you can
decide which account
to authorize in.
So that was something that
was not possible before.
Whichever default account when
you logged into your browser,
we pick that up.
So that's really important.
And now the fact that I can
click accept as a developer
and the script just picks up and
runs, so I don't have to
go back and hit Run again.
That's something that I think a
lot of people have probably
gotten used to, but now we
actually continue the
execution process after
the authorization.
That's really, really nice.
And then the other big developer
benefit is that if
you are using Google API, the
advanced services that we
offer, one of the nice things is
that before you had to copy
and paste a API key from a
developer console project that
you created manually and
you're supposed to
synchronize the keys.
Now we create a project for
you automatically just by
enabling the project that's
OAuth2 enabled, which is all
new projects.
KALYAN REDDY: At the developer
console, just to be clear,
it's the Google API's console.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Sorry.
The Google API's console.
I call it the developer
console a lot.
It's very confusing, I know.
This is the one that
you get by
code.google.com/apis/console.
And you can see that the project
name is the same as
the script name.
And it takes you right to the
services panel where you can
enable a service, or you can
automatically go and--
if I just enable a service,
let's just take the adminsdk
for a second, agree to it,
and you get the key
automatically created.
And we pick up the key for you,
and you don't have to
copy and paste this key in.
So this is automatically enabled
for your script.
So this becomes a lot easier for
developers to just use new
services without having
to think about which
keys they're using.
I probably picked
a bad example.
I should have gone with the
Tasks API, something that we
support in this list, but you
get the idea of how that has
become a lot better as well.
So bottom line, the
authorization process has
gotten a lot better for
developers, a lot better for
end users, and we really hope
that this allows you to build
more very interesting
applications, without a lot of
hand-holding for end users.
KALYAN REDDY: And if you do want
this for your existing
scripts you can just still do
the upgrade authorization
experience that you
get from the file.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Since this is a brand new script
I created, if I go
under File, this is greyed out
because that's already enabled
for you, but for your existing
scripts please turn that on
and you'll, I think, really
enjoy what that brings to you.
And let us know if you have any
issues and at some point
we will remove this option
all-together.
The next thing that we want to
talk about is a community
member, [? Kaisuke Osahi ?],
I think I'm saying his name
correctly, built a really
interesting application using
the import export API that we
launched about a month ago
that allows you to get access
to your source code from an
external application or Python
app or node app--
KALYAN REDDY: This
is the Drive API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: This is the
Drive API that allows you to
get and set source code off our
Google Apps script project.
And he has actually built some
really interesting tools.
So the first tool that he built
was a no-js application
that allowed you to essentially
mirror your source
on an app script project
on your local hard
drive and edit locally.
Really nice job.
I had a chance to try it out.
Works really well.
It requires a bit of a set up
so that I can get my refresh
tokens and things like that
which, one time experience
from the apps scripts with the
Google APIs playground, OAuth2
playground, I should say.
And then from there
on it just worked.
You just run this command line
and it automatically
synchronizes your code.
What he's also done is he's
taken that and then wrap it
into a Sublime Text plug-in.
So here so that the markup file
that essentially allows
you to set up your Sublime Text
to, when you hit Save,
runs the code to save it up
to the apps script API.
So it's got a couple of screen
shots that kind of shows you
that in action.
KALYAN REDDY: And Sublime, if
you're not familiar, is an
editor with nice default syntax
highlighting that a lot
of us here use.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
And you probably saw me use it
in my demo of the app script
import export API.
So nice job, [? Kaisuke ?].
Really, really excited
to show this off.
And a really good example of
a community member posting
something on the G Plus apps
script community, and we'll
pick it up and we'll share.
So Yeah.
Definitely let us know if you
build anything interesting,
and we'll share with
the audience here.
So yeah.
Just wanted to give a quick
plug to [? Kaisuke ?].
I know a lot of people want to
develop outside of the script
editor, and now it's possible.
It takes a little bit of effort,
and we're always
looking for ways where the
community members are
improving that experience
for the larger audience.
Cool.
You want to take
some questions?
Are there any one on
the live Hangout?
All right.
I think we have a bunch of
people on the Hangout.
If there are any questions
please go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Yes, Hello.
My name is Harry
[? Ausfein ?].
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hi, Harry,
how are you?
MALE SPEAKER: And I think I like
the new authorization.
I would like it even more if you
could share the screen so
we could see what
you were doing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh, I'm sorry.
KALYAN REDDY: Oh, it
did not go up.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think the
screen may not be visible in
the Hangout.
I think if you watch the
YouTube session.
So maybe there's just an issue
with the screen sharing with
the Hangout.
We apologize.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll check
back on YouTube then.
My question is about a
script that I have.
It's running in a background.
There's five or six
hundred users.
And if I upgrade the
authorization does it mean
that all users get a list of
errors that they have to
reauthorize?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That
is correct.
So let me just repeat the
question in case the folks on
YouTube or recorded
can't hear it.
The question from Harry was, I
have several hundred users
using my app that they've
previously authorized and
running on the background.
If I say, upgrade authorization
experience, will
they need to reauthorize?
And the answer is yes.
That's why we're not doing this
automatically for you.
We think it's an important
developer experience,
developer step to turn this on
because of this end user
authorization process.
It's really tricky to
convert OAuth1 based
grant to OAuth2 grants.
And there's some security issues
that we have to be
concerned with.
So end users do need
to reauthorize it.
If you release a new feature
perhaps that's the right time
to rolls it in.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly, yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So, yeah.
There is some planning
required.
Good question.
And I think it's stated in the
documentation that that's required.
But we should be very clear
that if you upgrade
authorization experience on your
project, end users will
need to reauthorize
your scripts.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So better wait for
next upgrade.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Uhh, yep.
Yeah.
So you'll have to
plan that out.
Good point, Harry.
Any other questions?
Cool.
So while we're waiting for
questions, let's go down the
list of questions on Moderator,
actually.
There's quite a few folks that
posted ahead of time.
Do you want to start taking
some of these questions?
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, sure.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'll
jump in as well.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
It would be great if we could
have some sort of quotas app
API to know the current state
of my scripts used or
remaining quotas.
Currently it's a black box.
You don't have any predictions
on when your script will
suddenly fail.
So unfortunately that's true.
We don't currently have this
functionality to know, for
most services.
For certain services
there is a method.
So for example, the mail
service has [INAUDIBLE]
remaining daily limits.
So the essence of this question
is, does this exist
in the general case
and can we get it?
So that's something that
we're looking at.
For right now, if you want
to implement some of this
functionality, you can do it
in the form of like a try
catch statement.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So if you don't want your script
to just throw an error
to the user, you could catch
that error and then you could
present it in a nicer way, or
you could retry it behind the
scenes if it's like a rate
issue, for example.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
right, yeah.
So there's a combination
of a few things here.
Obviously you want to make
this very transparent and
visible, so we're working on
ways where we can improve
this, either through an API or
some sort of other tools that
you may be able to inspect
your API usage.
It's nothing to announce
at this point.
We're looking at this
and we're really
aware of this issue.
And it's something that we feel
ourselves when we build
scripts internally.
Keep staring issues on
the issue tracker.
Make sure that you put a lot
of good details into issue
tracker, and get people on the
Google Plus community to star
it as well, to put their
use cases in.
We'll definitely continue
to look at this.
The one thing to keep in mind
is that a lot of the quotas
are actually pretty good, if
you're writing it to run as
the end user.
So if you write a script as
a web app, or as a Google
document sidebar app, or
something along those lines,
the person that opens
the document,
it uses their quotas.
Which, for them, it should be
sufficient to create calendar
events or scanning email.
So you have to be really
thinking about the quotas.
Think about, is it running as
the user, the owner of the
script, or is it running as
the user at the keyboard?
So if you think about that
oftentimes your about to run
it as the user at the keyboard,
you might be able to
do more with the quotas.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
And the general rule of thumb
is, if you're providing a
service that operates on each
user's inbox, or something
that's tailored for each
individual, then you should
probably try to use
their quota.
Because their operations really
should be debited to
their individual accounts.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
The next one is, do you have
any tips or best practices
when using app script to monitor
calendar events?
Oh, it just updated.
New questions came in.
Let me just take that question
from, I think it
was Will, in Boston.
It's a really good question.
It's something that we think the
best way to do it would be
using the push notification
scheme that we have, getting
sort of alerts or triggers or
something along those lines.
Today there is no good way to do
that, just to kind of jump
ahead and talk about
the other question.
To receive a push notification
you have to be able to
authorize the URL, you
have to be able
to accept HTTP headers.
Those are things that
are not very
straightforward with app script.
So, as of now, a polling based
system is probably the easiest
way to do it.
And you can get clever with it
including search parameters,
and including date parameters
to make sure you're only
polling on as small a
subset as possible.
But without that, I can't really
think of a much more
creative way to do this.
KALYAN REDDY: And for example,
if you already got all the
events for certain dates in the
past, then you can only
start looking for events for
and you can restrict the
search dates to be,
you know, tomorrow
until the future time.
And then you can keep on
incrementing that as well.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: If you remember
the last time poll,
then you can keep moving the
window to get the smallest
response set possible for you
to do something effectively.
Let's do the next one.
I would like to embed Apps
Script into Docs or Sheets
programmatically.
This will be possible in the
future, when will the Script
Gallery improve?
A-ha.
So you're saying Script Gallery
is not good enough?
So it's a really
good question.
As you can imagine, I think at
Google I/O [? Glen Sarab ?]
and Jonathan [? Rasher ?], they
showed off the Google
Docs experience, how you can
write scripts for it.
We had not included the Script
Gallery for Docs and we had
mentioned that we're looking at
ways to holistically make
that much better.
That's a process.
That's an important
project for us.
And so the answer for this is,
the Google Script Gallery will
improve, and that'll
be the answer.
And that will allow you to do
a lot better things as a
developer, and for
your end users.
KALYAN REDDY: And as far as the
programmatic aspect, do
you think they want to have
another script that attaches
this script to--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, I was
trying to make sense
out of that, too.
There's a couple ways you
could do-- there was a
question on Stack Overflow which
we answered where, if
you have like a template
document that has a script
associated with it, if you copy
it using the Drive APIs
that we offer in Apps Script,
you'll get the script
associated with it.
That's one way to distribute
a document
and a script together.
Another way is to use libraries,
where you have a
library that's included
by your script.
And that library will be
available in every copy of
that document.
I think, if you want to be able
to programmatically open
up a document, inject some
script code and do it, as of
now we're not really
considering that.
Pretty complicated
to have that, and
security-wise as well.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
Any more questions on
the web hangout?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Just speak up
on the live Hangout if you
have any questions.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, we'll
keep the mike on.
All right.
I'll take the next one here.
What do we have?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The
ScriptDb one.
KALYAN REDDY: I like to use
ScriptDb but tests show that
it's slow on data writes,
even in batch.
400 object writes in about
37 seconds [INAUDIBLE]
speed it up.
So using batch writes, I guess
it generally depends on how
large your objects are.
That determines the speed
at which it writes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
I haven't taken a look at this
particular question.
So in general, yes, the plans
are to continue to make
ScriptDb, just the whole
system, faster.
So if there any specific
instances like this, certainly
log an enhancement request with
reasonable details on
what tests you've conducted.
And again, build consensus
around it.
ScriptDb continues to be
experimental as of now.
So if you are looking for ways
to store data in a much more
robust production quality system
I would use something
like Cloud SQL or
Cloud Datastore.
Other systems that Google offers
that has building and
quotas and a much
more production
capable systems available.
So that's something that I
would look at, is if your
performance is really slow, take
a look at some of those
other systems that we
have access to.
KALYAN REDDY: And you can also
use the JDBC service to
connect to an external database
using App Script.
ScriptDb is really nice if you
want to do something quick.
If you want a script that's used
by either just yourself
or a couple of users and you
want throw small objects in
there and retrieve them.
It's perfect for
that situation.
But if you want to do anything
serious, you know, have large
objects or lots of objects, you
do want to consider some
of these other connectors
that we expose.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And I've written scripts that
have saved thousands of
objects, and it does take a few
dozen second sometimes.
But if you're doing it the sort
of asynchronous process
or the user doesn't have to wait
for that, there might be
better ways to also not let
the user see that issue.
All right.
Next one.
KALYAN REDDY: We covered
the events one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The
next question--
we should probably go
into presentation
mode here, I think.
Let's see where the presentation
mode is.
I forget where the link is.
I apologize.
It's sorting as you guys are
voting on these questions.
All right, we'll just
pick off something.
When using new authorization
flow it would be great to be
able to add additional
scopes and then
automatically insert tokens.
Yes.
That's a great question.
So let me rephrase this.
So today we pick up OAuth scopes
that a script needs by
evaluating the project and
looking at all the API's a
project the script is using.
That list is today opaque
to the script developer.
So you don't get too add or
remove scopes that we have
evaluated from your script.
The question here is, we would
like to be able to specify our
own scopes along with what the
script needs so that we could
use that scope for, the token
for, other calls that we may
be making, like with the, I
don't know, the Google Glass
API or something like that
that we may have.
It's a really good
feature request.
You should log this in the
issue tracker, I think.
It's something that we are
very much thinking about.
It's a really good idea
and something
that we want to support.
No time frames, unfortunately.
It's a tricky one.
Let's see.
A quota question around
ScriptDb.
I think something that, again
no new announcements here.
Something that you have to kind
of manually watch for
now, how much you're inserting,
do some fuzzy math
to, say, if my object size in
general is about 500 bytes I
have this many inserts
I can do.
So you kind of have to
keep an eye on that.
And there's no good way to ask
a ScriptDb instance how many
objects are in there, quickly.
And, more importantly, how much
space it's occupying.
KALYAN REDDY: But there are
methods that let you know that
after you performed a series
of writes, if they all
succeeded or not.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
KALYAN REDDY: So we have
examples on our
using ScriptDb page.
You can go and get the
snippet there.
And basically it iterates and
calls all OK method and then
just see that if it's
successfully wrote to the
database or not.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
The next question's about the
source code of a library.
Really good question around,
can a script developer, if
they distribute their project as
a library for other scripts
to use, can they rely on their
script to be invisible, the
code to be invisible from the
script developers, and the
answer is no.
So you can in fact look at the
source code of a library.
The reason is that we think of
library as a way to distribute
functionality, not a way
to hide keys or other
functionality implementation
details.
So if you are really interested
in sharing
execution code, the best way
might be to do it as a web app
where you publish it as a web
app or as a content service
application.
Because then all you're sharing
with your end users is
a URL, rather than a library
which allows them to look at
your source code, but not
change it or execute--
I guess it allows them
to execute it.
So it's a good question.
I think our library's page
makes that clear.
If not, it should.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
So basically, in order for
people to use your library
they need to have at least
view permissions so that
allows them to view
the script source.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
right, yes.
It's not a foolproof way to
secure your source code.
It's really just a way to share
code rather than to lock
away stuff.
Push notifications.
We spoke about that in the
context of calendar.
Same thing applies here.
Let's see.
That only support OAuth1.
AppEngine cloud endpoints
limitation which uses OAuth2.
What's the best practice with
Apps Script accessing these
Cloud endpoints given apps
only supports OAuth1?
So it's a really
good question.
I'll respond to this on
the moderator as well.
So OAuth2 actually is much more
straightforward decoded
yourself versus OAuth1.
OAuth1 required you to do
cryptography on the message
and create this thing called the
nonce which was sort of a
time-based setting that
you had to track.
So while we have built-in OAuth1
support you can always
do OAuth2 by yourself.
So you can publish your
web app an endpoint to
receive the call back.
And there's several
examples of this.
If you look at my Google I/O
2013 presentation on the
YouTube Analytics API, Github
had the whole code posted,
including how you can
get refresh tokens.
So one time authorization that
grabs an offline grant and
just behind the scenes
every hour gets a
new token, if needed.
So it's a one time process to
authorize your script, along
with the OAuth2.
And then from there on it's good
to go and running as the
end user that authorized it.
So the bottom line is,
it's possible.
It does require a bit
more time to set up.
Let's see.
KALYAN REDDY: The final
question, I need to buy more
quotas in Google Apps Script.
We are definitely aware that
this is a feature that users
would like.
Started on issue tracker.
Nothing to announce at
this time for this.
But if more and more users
require this functionality
we'll definitely
look into that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Just wanted to quickly
look through it.
There's a question around
converting from
UI App to HTML service.
I'll just very quickly
respond to that.
UI app is still supported.
So no need to jump or anything
along those lines.
But we do think HTML service
will provide much more
flexibility and we'll keep
looking at ways to provide
more samples.
[? Eric Coleta ?]
recently shared some
really good samples
around the tasks API.
Please take a look at
that for some best
practices and sample code.
I think we're approaching
time.
KALYAN REDDY: I just want to
throw out there that we do
have some more extended samples
currently in the works
that show functionality on how
to get HTML service running.
We understand that UI app is
like a dead simple thing.
This is what you do here, this
is what you do here, and
you're done.
So that's upcoming.
Stay tuned, keep a look out on
our developer page, and then
you'll find these
as they come in.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Lots of really good questions.
I think we're up on time.
We'll schedule this again, and
we're hoping to hear more
questions and future requests
and ideas from you guys.
We'll also continue to answer
questions in the moderator as
we get them.
All right.
Thank you very much and looking
forward to chatting
with you guys again.
KALYAN REDDY: Thanks
for tuning in.